first of all let's get the matter of
introductions out of the way if you
don't Bob garstin Charlie Thomas here
goes this is Bob Bart
if you see them again this winter you
won't be wearing a hat stand either
and here's cha Thomas whose constant
attention to growing and processing seed
corn is your crop insurance for next
year the result of this partnership is
an institution dedicated to the
production of superior seed corn the
largest and most modern plant in
existence more than a hundred thousand
bushels of pioneer hybrid seed were
dried sorted graded and back here this
year the warehouse 300 feet long and
with a capacity of more than 40,000
bushels was recently built to
accommodate the increasing volume when I
met you a moment ago I knew you were
here to find out the house why of hybrid
car and how and why issues will put more
money in your pocket but before we see
what has been done with hybrid corn
let's take a look at a field of open
pollinated corn
I think you'll recognize maybe we can
refresh your memory about the false and
the flaws of open pollinated torn
anywhere in the Corn Belt fields of open
pollinated corn greet the eye this one
isn't a bad feel in fact it's pretty
good but it won't bear close inspection
garstin Thomas have thousands of
visitors every fall to insist upon
seeing the difference between open
pollinated corns and pioneer hi-bred
corn no worse than the average field yet
there's a decided lack of stiffness here
which is notably present in the hybrid
field your to visit later you will
observe a general lack of stiffness and
style looks like the cows have been in
the corn
there's an appearance of sagginess due
mostly to fall in stocks stocks that
break before the ears mature cause
chappy and rotten ears not sound corn
and not conducive to large yields
the stocks upon which these ears were
produced went down early with resultant
rottenness of the ear limber stocks are
easily blown down that are difficult to
pick either by hand or by machine
when the wind is accompanied by rain the
fallen stock attempts to come up again
and in so doing forms a gooseneck
another reason for stocks falling is a
poor weak root system a typical fault of
open pollinated corn later you will
contrast this root with the heavy
pioneer hi-bred root the lack of
uniformity in plaintive ears of open
pollinated form slows down picking
materially for this reason corn picking
contests are practically always held in
high bred fields where the contestants
show to the greatest advantage the
uneven position of ears seen here does
not permit rapid or efficient Huskie
another fault of open pollinated corn is
the fact that the ears themselves drop
off so easily on windy days
a mechanical corn picker can't pick up
these ears a human corn pickers doesn't
like to
after the corn picker has been through
the open-pollinated field the job of
picking up volunteers yet remains this
extra task is wholly unnecessary in the
pioneer hi-bred fields which you'll soon
see 10% of the corn was left on the
ground too much to leave but a lot of
work to get and here's what you finally
do get on you know form size shape and
quality reason for the lack of
uniformity and figure in the field that
we've just looked at is that you don't
know which pollen grains pollinated each
separate pound in other words you don't
know who the daddy was no one would be
so foolish as to try to improve
livestock without selecting the finest
sire the we didn't you get a
prize-winning bull or a good boar is
because some breeder has selected his
grandparents with the greatest of care
now let's take a look at a field of
Pioneer hybrid corn where we do know the
father from the grandfather in fact we
know all of the ancestry for ten
generations back the cloud gets larger
you know what they say about building a
better mousetrap this is daily routine
during harvest time at the garstin
Thomas plant in Coon Rapids where
visitors are welcome seeing is believing
here's an example of what plan Deere
hybrid seed corn will do for you
there's an ear on every stock the ears
are at a uniform height and the stops
are standing up stiff straight and
strong and the ears will bear plenty of
inspection to again the uniformity of
height is extremely noticeable product
of two adjacent hills three emphasizes
the uniformity of the ears for size type
and quality they're a noonday meal for
any horse pioneer produces corn of real
quality it's good feed and it markets at
top prices what all of you who've
marveled at 100 bushels per acre yields
you're now seeing 110 bushels to the
acre what do you think of this
neighborhood of healthy ears called the
gold coast by one visitor 110 bushels to
the acre means eighty eight hundred
pounds of ear corn it takes sturdy stops
to hold up this kind of a crop how
beautifully they stand we can even see
angle wise or crosswise through the corn
field take a look down that aisle a
pathway to prosperity
and what's more the ears don't fall off
when the wind blows
remember how easily they fill in the
other fields smoke that one in your pipe
mr. corn can't stand up without a root
system either go ahead pull it out it
can be done but it takes plenty of help
these roots go down where the plants
grooving Morse your arms
they oughta produce coins they've had
plenty of opportunity to absorb a lot of
nourishment from the soil and they did
produce a lot of corn roots tell a lot
of the story of pioneer hi-bred corn
which one of these two roots do you
think has the best chance to get down
where the moisture in plant food are
which one will hold the stock the
straightest a pioneer hi-bred root is
four times as large the mechanical
quantico also gets a real chance to do a
good job in hybrid corn sooner or later
all farmers will be using the corn
thicker the heavy root system sturdy
straight stops and strong shanks of
Pioneer hybrids are well adapted to
mechanical for kicking this is corn
raising reduced to a science in a few
minutes that wagon will be back full of
corn from four rows seventy rods long
when picking corn by hands or
mechanically how convenient it is to
find the ear at a uniform height on
every stop there aren't two inches
difference in the height of ears just to
show that these individual hills aren't
unusual for this pioneer field
let's pick three consecutive hills how
uniform they are in height found nicely
they break out
and what fun to pick these golden ears
and man what a profit three adjacent
Hills nine big fine quality ears harder
to hold them to husk over here the
convict has already made one round 70
rods long and here's the tape
hold on there old boy over then we can't
blame you at that they'd never believe
you're back home if you didn't have some
corn to back it up and over in the
corner of the field the loaded wagons
are done the coin elevated on the
waiting trucks and headed for the
processing plant in one day three men
with a corn picker have picked two
thousand bushels from 19 acres of land
and loaded it onto the trucks again we
repeat barn-raising reduced to a science
and so to town it goes while we spring
along behind
let's glance at the field that was
picked with the sturdy straight pollen
rows left standing the corn from these
pollen rows is never used for seed but
is later picked and fed
you